her heart is broken Lisa we all love you
days after Lisa Marie was laid to rest
Priscilla Presley says it's been a dark
Journey now she is home where she always
belonged but my heart is missing her
love
just over two weeks ago Lisa Marie died
after suffering Cardiac Arrest at home
in the wake of losing her child
Priscilla shares with fans on Twitter
she's overwhelmed with your words your
prayers your love and your support
adding every parent who has lost a
daughter or son knows what a dark
painstaking Journey it is
police Marie knew that Journey too her
only son Brandon died by suicide in
2020.
the Elise news
too long
childhood passes by
with a glimpse of her green eye
she then grew a family of her own
then came her second child
leaving her with suspicion
could this be the angel that takes me
home
time of course flew by it was time for a
tragedy
she knew what was close to the end
survivors
guilt some would say but a broken heart
was the doing of her death
now she is home where she always
belonged but my heart is missing her
love
I'm going to read something Riley wrote
Priscilla's granddaughter Riley and
husband Ben's eulogy revealed Lisa Marie
became a grandmother shortly before her
death
thank you for showing me that love is
the only thing that matters in this life
I hope I can love my daughter the way
you love to me the way you loved my
brother my sisters thank you for giving
me strength my heart my empathy my
courage I'm a product of your heart
my sisters are a product of your heart
my brother is a product of your heart
we are you you are us my eternal love
she's so level-headed I love her and
she's much further advanced than I ever
was
Days Later Riley shared her final photo
taken with Lisa Marie in the caption she
reflected on feeling blessed and
grateful to have the snapshot of her
last moment spent with her beautiful
mama I don't know what to do with myself
I'm not if I'm not a mom back in
Priscilla's message on Thursday she
tells the world thank you from the
bottom of my heart and trying to help me
get through this loss my late
mother-in-law used to say that nothing
can be said can begin to take away the
anguish and the pain of these moments
because grief is the price we pay for
love
and how right she was